Hello everybody. This is All Quiet on
the Inner Front. I'm Alex Ray and I'm
very uh lucky today to be joined by
Professor Xang Shu Ching um the star of
predictive history and um a very popular
voice on on YouTube these days bringing
new frameworks of understanding to the
world uh of our past and the world
around us at the present.
Um, Professor Jang, um, I think your
your popularity in the last year in
particular has, um, really captured a
lot of people's,
uh,
understanding of the missing elements of
history and the way we understand the
world. um particularly through your
incorporation of uh psychological and
spiritual nuances and elements in
looking at human societies and human
motivations.
Um I think you briefly described this as
psycho history on the introduction in
your channel. Um could you uh tell us a
little bit more about how you came to
see this as a more um nuanced and
appropriate approach to history as
opposed to I think what the sort of uh
status quo um orthodox approach that
many people would have grown up with at
in high school and um what are the extra
nuanced elements of psychology and
spirituality that you feel necessary to
bring into any understanding of history.
>> Yeah. So, um it's a long story, but you
know, when I was growing up um in
Toronto, um I was an immigrant child in
Toronto. I didn't have that many friends
and I was bullied a lot, so I retreated
into the library. I read a lot of books.
Um I was a huge fan of science fiction.
So, um, my favorite, of course, was
Isaac Aszimov, um, the psycho history,
but I also read, you know, Ray
Bradberry,
um, and, um, I also love John Weinham.
The day of the day of the triits is one
of my favorite books. Um, Isaac Azimov,
um, I absorbed, I read all of his books
because it was so easy for me to read.
Now, it's interesting because at my age,
looking back and trying to read reread
the Foundation series, it's unreadable.
It is the most horrendously written
books out there. It is I mean the man is
illiterate. It's almost impossible to
read um as an adult but as a child um it
it seemed as though I was sympatical
with his worldview. Um you know the
foundation series was this vast
expanding universe and the main argument
is that um if you study if you take like
micro samples like m micro data and you
look at tens of thousands of years of
human history you you understand that
there are patterns that emerge and then
you can take these patterns and then
mathematically model them and then
create this framework in which you can
actually predict what's going to happen.
Um, and there'll be different crisis
points and then there'll be different
solutions to these crisis points. And
even though there might be some
divergences, but you always end up in
the same place. Now, and and this is
true only because at the macro level,
right? You're talking you're talking
about like trillions of people in the
Foundation world, you're talking about
like tens of thousands of years. And
that was his argument um in the
Foundation series. And that's something
that's an idea that stayed with me my
entire life. Um my life took a sharp
divergence when I went to Yale. Okay.
Because you know I was a poor immigrant
in Toronto
and I was a marginalized um individual
and then I go to Yale which is really
the center of the universe right this is
where all the children of the elite go
and um even though I myself was not that
successful at Yale I mean success I was
successful academically. I mean I did
well in school but you know Yale is not
a place where you uh go and learn
knowledge. Y is a place where you meet
the connections uh build the social
network that will carry you for the rest
of your life. So for so example classic
example is George W. Bush. George W.
Bush when he went to Yale, he was a
cheerleader and he was a C student, but
he um was on a first-name basis with
every one of his classmates at Yale and
they stayed together for um you know
they stayed as friends for the rest of
their lives. I met his roommate once uh
his his roommate is uh Sandy Rant and he
was a lawyer in Hong Kong when I met him
and you know he went to Hodkkins and
went to Yale and he ended up as um
George W. Bush's um ambassador to
Beijing. um when when he was president.
So it's a very close network and and I
was a marginalized part of this network
but I imbued I absorbed a lot of their
values and a lot of their um
intellectual framework for the world and
basically the framework it's a very
simple one in which that the best ideas
always triumph and the best individuals
the best talent will always triumph and
that's a story of history it's a
theological history towards progress
towards enlightenment and that's
something that um I believe for the
longest time. But then you know after I
gradu from Yale I started to fail uh
through life. Um and you know I started
out as a high school teacher in Beijing.
Then I worked as a a journalist um for
the chronicle high education. Then I
became a doctorate filmmaker. I also
worked for the United Nations at some
point. And then all this time um it it
was a long period of cognitive
dissonance which drove me into into
depression because you know I went to
Yale and I believe that um people are
inherently good and that good will
triumph in the end. But then you know
working at the United Nations and seeing
all this corruption um being in China
and seeing all this u incompetence
um and just meeting people who were
extremely successful and then you're
like I don't know why they succeeded
because these are mediocre individuals.
So I had a and and I I myself was just
floundering through life. Um I I I I
wrote like three books all of which
failed. Um, I was unemployed for the
longest time for like a couple years. I
was like literally living in my parents'
basement playing Starcraft from like I
think 6:00 p.m. until 5:00 a.m. I was
like a vampire. Um, and I lived my life
like online and but it felt safe because
once I stepped outdoors, once I started
to meet with meet people, people
confused me. the the the human world
confused me because it was not the way
that logically it was supposed to work.
And so um after a long bout of
depression um I started to
begin to resurrect or develop a new
understanding of how the world works.
And um at this time I I started to play
poker. Okay. I played um Texas Hold on
poker and what I re what I recognized is
that when you play poker, you play any
game, it seems as though every
individual has a distinct strategy of
how to play this game. And this
strategy, you may not think it's
logical, but he's winning money. So, it
does work. All right. So, there are
different types of poker players. And I
started to like study different games
and I recognized that wow like in every
game you're going to have a diversity a
range of strategies and these strategies
may may not be optimal for you but
they're optimal for the other person.
Okay. So human humans are diverse and
each person has an optimal strategy
according to his personality according
to their circumstance. And so once I
started to appreciate and apply
psychology to game theory, then I
started to have a much more nuance uh
and a much more uh realistic
understanding of how the the world
works. And a major breakthrough was, you
know, like six years ago, um I have a
good friend, his name is David Brahmich,
and he was my professor mentor at Yale.
He's starting professor of English at
Yale, and he's he's really the smartest
man I I know. And I made a point of
staying in touch with him like for for
for for decades. And um
we had these email exchanges because you
know Trump had won the presidency and
there was all these DI politics at the
universities at Yale that was confusing
him. So we would have these like um
email conversations. At first he got in
touch because he wanted to know what the
culture cultural revolution was like in
China. And I I told him like you know
what's happen what happened in the 70s
in China is exactly what's happening
right now in the United States on
college campuses. And so so we we
develop very long uh uh close email
relationship. And then we start to
transition to talk about geopolitics. We
started to talk about why Putin invaded
um uh Ukraine. Um will Trump uh win
2020? Um so so so we went through all
these geopolitics and then I recognized
that whatever I was doing my entire life
the system of analysis that I developed
in intellectual framework I developed
had a good way of predicting how events
would unfold. All right so I predicted
that uh Putin would invade Ukraine. I
predicted that Trump would win 2020 but
if he didn't win 2020 then he would run
again in 2024 and he would win. I pred I
predicted the war in uh Iran. And so I I
was you know in these email exchanges um
that I had you know I'm very thankful
for David Brahmage because you know he
really inspired me really mentored me in
this process. I recognized that um I
could I could explain why the world was
working uh the way it was. Um and so um
a couple years ago I started to teach a
class on geo strategy on geopolitics and
I filmed it and I put it on uh YouTube
and um I made certain predictions uh for
so for example I predicted that Trump
would win 2024. He would become
president again. I predicted that um um
Trump would attack Iran. I I predicted
that uh there'd be a civil war in um
America at some point. um possibly by
2028 I predicted that Putin would uh win
the war in Ukraine and he would move and
capture Odessa. Okay, so these are all
predictions that are turning out to be
accurate and that's what allow me to
blow up on on the internet. So um so so
yeah so I would say that my framework it
it it's an appreciation that at the end
of the day human society it's a game and
there are different players and we have
to understand the psychology of these
major players okay people like Putin and
Trump if we are to understand how the
world works because at the end of the
day it's not ideas that ultimately win
out it's these individuals that must
play the game and they're going to play
the game that um maximizes their best
interests and if we see the world that
way um then I think it makes more much
more sense. So I' I've been using this
analysis uh game theory analysis
um to understand geopolitics and it's
turned out pretty well. Okay. So, um,
most recently,
um, we, um, I was I was on some
geopolitical podcast and, um, I kept on
arguing that this, uh, American war in
Venezuela makes absolutely no sense
whatsoever. You look from a game theory
perspective,
um, what Trump is doing doesn't really
make any sense because a lot of people
are saying, well, he's he wants it for
the oil. I'm like, well, if he wants the
oil, he can just buy the oil, right? And
that's that's what's happening right now
where Delsey Rodriguez, the new
president of Venezuela had is issuing
new laws that make it much easier for
the private ownership of um Venezuela uh
oil companies, the the Venezuela oil
sector. Okay. So he could he he could
have done that like you know before.
Okay. And so I kept on saying that. It
was but it was unclear to me why he was
doing that because I didn't have enough
information to work with. I just knew
like the standard geopolitical
explanation that he wants to see oil
doesn't really make sense. Okay. And
then what happened of course was that um
Maduro was kidnapped. Um the Delta Force
went in, blew us blew our stuff up
including the mausoleum of Hugo Chavez
and um
um kidnapped Maduro and they they
paraded him for the streets of New York.
And then it clicked to me why this is
happening. Okay, it clicked to me why
they did this. And the answer is first
of all Maduro must be a CIA asset
because there's no other explanation for
how it was so easily done. It could have
only been done with the cooperation of
those inside. The idea that Deli
Rodriguez, the vice president, betrayed
um uh Maduro is just ridiculous because
this guy Maduro was in power for 13
years. So he has a political sense. I
mean he's not an idiot. I mean he may be
stupid if you talk to him about
geopolitics, about mathematics. He
doesn't know any of this stuff. But
political survival, um, game theory, he
he understands a lot. And so, um, I
don't think anyone betrayed him. I think
that he was always a CIA asset because
he had to be in order to to survive that
long. If he were not, they would have
assassined him a long time ago. Um, and
um, he had Cuban bodyguards and
basically they were there to keep him in
prison and D force went in to extract
him. They they went to extricate him
from the situation. And the deal is that
Maduro will be put on trial. Uh I don't
know when. I mean it's gonna happen
soon. Now Maduro is gonna say two
things. Okay. The first thing he's gonna
say is that Venezuela
um participates in drug smuggling and
therefore the Americans were right to
arrest me for knuckle trafficking. Okay.
This was a legitimate pretext for
arresting me. And number two is, and
this is most important, is that he has
evidence that the Democrats stole the
2020 election using spmatic machines.
Okay? So smartmatic machines are um
voting machines that they use in
Venezuela. And and and he's going to
tell you how it's possible to rig the
smartmatic machines. And then it's going
to prove that yes, the Democrats did
steal the 2020 election. In return,
Trump's going to um pardon him. Okay. Uh
you know, both he and his wife were
extricated from Venezuela. So, it seems
as though there was an agreement already
in place. And so, so again, this is a
prediction that I make and we'll we'll
see in a month or two whether or not
this prediction holds out. But again,
like this is game theory analysis to
geopolitics where before it's like,
okay, it's just oil. No, no, no, no.
What does Trump want and what does
Maduro want? Right? Trump wants to
overturn the 2020 election and get a
third term. Right? If he's able to prove
to the American people that in fact the
Democrats stole the 2020 election,
>> then this justifies him running for a
third term and and I think he will win
by landslide. I think that 2028 I I
would not be surprised if it was a Trump
versus Obama matchup. And I would not
and in that situation Trump would win
easily. Okay? Okay. I guarantee you if
that were that was a matchup, Obama
would be destroyed, especially with the
release of the Epson files, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, so you have to ask yourself why this
is happening? Why why this Venezuela um
kidnapping of Maduro, why the release of
Epson files, right? Um
and if you just look at Trump as a
player and he's trying to get a third
term and he's trying to become king of
the United States, then all this makes
sense. Ultimately, his greatest enemy in
achieving a third term are not the
Democrats. It's a deep state. Okay? So
from his perspective, it was not the
Democrats who rigged the 2020 election.
It was a deep state or a certain faction
of the deep state um that was financed
by C CIA drug money that allowed um the
Democrats to win to that allowed Joe
Biden to win. And so he needs to attack
these people. And you can do that
through, you know, Maduro. You can also
do that through the Epson files. You can
also do that through um um Palunteer and
Peter Teal, right? getting them to um
overturn the the the deep state install
a new deep state. Okay, so that's what
Trump Donald Trump is doing and that and
so like you know everyone thinks Donald
Trump is an idiot. He may be an idiot.
Okay, I mean like I think if he if you
were to ask him to write a paper uh a
speech he it would be a terrible
terrible speech but in terms of like
personality politics in terms of like
political man manipulation in terms like
controlling optics
um then I think he's he's the best in
the world. I think he's a super athlete
in terms of uh political manipulation
and controlling political perception.
Okay? And that's the idea of game theory
like like for him to be in this position
he needs to be the best at what he does.
Okay? So ask yourself what does he do
really well and what is his ambition?
What what are are are his motivations?
What are his incentives? And what is
optimal strategy? If you look at that
way then what what he's doing makes
perfect sense. and and then you can make
you can extrapolate and make certain
predictions in that and and I and I
predict very I predict that he will win
a he will win a third term. I predict
that he will get a third term. In fact,
I will go as far to say he will get a
fourth term as well.
>> Fantastic. I mean the um [clears throat]
this the references that many people
have made to his time in the WWE I think
it is in the professional wrestling
scene seem to be ringing very true in
the way that he manages politics as form
of entertainment in a in a way as a as a
story as a show. I think you've
mentioned this uh quite often in your in
your lectures.
>> Okay. So so I'll I'll say this. Okay. I
will say that politics was always a
show. All right. So, so let let me give
an example. George HW Bush, George HW
Bush is in the Epstein files, right? And
the accusation against him is that he
was organizing these, you know, orgies
that we saw in white eyes wide shut
>> and there were satanic rituals. Um, and
you know what? It fits his personality.
Okay. So, let's go into some basic
background about George HW Bush. First
of all, we can guess that he was a
mastermind of Iran Contra, right?
Because Ronald Reagan is an actor,
whereas um George HW Bush was a deep
state operative since he was a teenager.
I mean, his family is CIA, deep state,
okay? The Bushes. Um and he went to
Andover. He was in uh Skull and Bones at
Yale. Okay. So, so he really is um the
secret um Satan that controls America.
Iron Contra was he masterminded that.
Okay. Now what's interesting is 1980s a
conduit for iron condro this drug smug
smuggling was Arkansas and who was
governor of Arkansas at that time Bill
Clinton right and we know I mean this is
well documented Bill Clinton and George
HW Bush are really good friends in fact
if you talk to people who know the two
um people will tell you that George HW
Bush saw Brooklyn as a son much more so
than than his own son George W Bush he
actually saw George W Bush as a bit of a
failure And here was Boke Clinton who
was very articulate, very charming, he
had a great future. And George HW Bush
really mentored Clinton. And so 1992
um when George HW Bush and Bill Clinton
were on stage debating, it was a show,
right? George HW Bush was perfectly
happy to give the presidency to Bill
Clinton because he's actually better off
in the shadows, right? Why is it that of
all the presidents we know least about
um the presidential afterlife of George
Ob George HW, right? We know that uh
Bill Clinton started the Clinton
Foundation. We know that Obama started
his foundation. We know that um uh
George HW Bush became a painter, right?
But we know nothing about the afterlife
uh president afterlife of George HW and
we can just assume that he went back to
being a spy to being this puppet master
around the world. Okay. So, um um Bill
Clinton was being mentored by George HW
Bush and you know a lot of his policies
George Hw would have enacted anyway,
right? He was trying to enact them like
NAFTA and most patient most favorite
nations trading status for China. this
new neoliberal agenda that was very much
part of the Reagan Bush years, but he
had problems implementing them because
of all the um uh push back from the
Democrats. Right? People don't people
don't remember this, but the Democrats
under Dip Gethart um in the 1980s was a
workingclass party that did not want
immigrants, that did not want free trade
and did not believe that China would be
a good trading partner because of
China's blatant abuse of human rights.
People forget all this. Okay. So, the
Democrats were the polar opposite of the
Republicans and Bill Clinton was a
perfect person to co-opt and destroy the
Democratic party from within, right?
From and make it more Republican. Okay?
So, you you can say the Democrats have
become Republican, Republicans have
become, you know, MAGA. All right? But
but think about the cooperation between
George HW Bush and Bill Clinton where
George HW could not have implemented his
policies under under Republican
administration but he could have done so
through a Clinton administration. Okay,
that's point number one. Point number
two is okay so uh his son wins and his
one son won because of the Supreme
Court, right? Um, so I think Senator Day
Connor was a deciding vote and you know,
so I'm sure his father made some phone
calls. But what happens right after his
son wins? 911 happens. Okay. And who's
the only person in the world who could
have orchestrated 911? George HW Bush,
right? Because it was all his people in
place, including Donald Ransfield, Dick
Cheney, uh, all all these people were
his people in place. And if you just
look at the Epstein files and the sort
of like the the um complicated satic
rituals that he organized. Yeah. He's
he's sort of the person to sort like
think that 911 is um he would want to
orchestrate something like 911. Okay.
And of course you have the war war on
terror. But then 20 uh 2004
that presidential election was very
interesting as well because who who who
are the candidates? John Kerry for the
Democrats,
>> George HW Bush. Sorry, George W. Bush
for the Republicans. Guess what? They're
both scaring bones, right? Who's the
lead of scone bones? George HW. Okay.
So, no matter what would have happened,
he would have won and the policies would
have continued. Okay?
>> Right? So, you could and then and then
and who comes next? Obama. Uh I'm not
sure if you know anything about Obama,
but but his family is clearly CIA. If
his family is clearly CIA, then he's
another puppet of George HW Bush. All
right? So it's just one continuous
regime, one continuous set of policies.
>> Yeah.
>> And but of course the major disruption
was Donald Donald Trump. All right. And
and but like so if you if you go back to
Ronald Reagan up until Obama, it's just
one clear
adal framework for how jails should be
run. And whenever they ran into into
stumbling blocks, they they um found a
candidate that could remove these c
these stumbling blocks, right? So Bill
Clinton removed the left um workingclass
objections to this regime. Then Obama uh
was able to um re like remove the
liberal objections, right? Because
remember identity politics.
>> Exactly. Right. Because remember why why
do we have identity politics? Because of
occupy Wall Street. Yeah.
>> Right. because 2008 um the entire global
elite showed how corrupt, how
incompetent they were by basically
destroying the global economy and then
occupy Washington. Occupy Washington was
a real thing. It had it had a
revolutionary tenure to it and Obama was
brought in to implement identity
politics. Okay. And so so that's how the
system works. So it's always been like
this.
>> So there's a few threads that I want to
bring together from what you've spoken
about so far. Um the first is that um
the vast majority of the population live
uh they grow up with certain stories
about the way the world works. Certain
self that they that they build into
their self-concept that they create as
assumptions like you mentioned like you
work hard and you will get ahead, you'll
be rewarded this sort of thing. Um, and
the other is that in reality there is
these stories are all part of the show
that people are indoctrinated into and
behind the scenes the world works in a
much more
uh almost incomprehensible
way in our knowledge of the way that
consciousness works. But also that is
not necessarily just a um
positive uh
sense of higher consciousness that this
uh higher consciousness can lend itself
towards evil use or immoral use and
that's what I have sort of understood
from the threads that you draw through
your lectures of when you've spoken
about ancient practices of religious
indoctrination and the origins of secret
societies all the way through to their
modern secular forms in the intelligence
agencies who are the indoctrinators of
the modern secular world and their
studies into mind control through
programs that we know about such as MK
Ultra and I'm sure many many others that
we don't know about. Um could you speak
to a bit about the implications of what
that means for the sort of facade of the
world that we think we see and the
actual nature of reality going on behind
it?
Yeah. Great. Okay. Yeah. So, um the best
metaphor to use in this instance is to
think about Plato's allegory of the
cave, right?
>> So, in Plato's out of the cave,
everyone's well like most people are
prisoners and they're chained to the
ground. Uh and their necks are shackled,
so they can't move around. Okay? And the
only thing they can stare at is a wall,
right? And the rulers of this world,
what they do is they have this fire
behind everyone. And this fire, they
have the these um these puppets. And
these puppets then um project onto the
wall. All right. And that's perfect
metaphor to understand the world we live
in where reality is manifestation of our
perceptions. Okay. Consciousness is what
gives rise to reality. If you want to
create reality then you have to be able
to control and direct the consciousness
of the majority of people. Okay. And
that's what the elite do. Um ever since
the beginning of time, right? So before
these people were called priests, right?
What what's the job of priests? priests
were to create a narrative about the
world that controlled and directed
people's consciences so that this
reality could be manifested uh with with
the priests at the very center. And this
is no different from the world we live
in today. Why do we have schools? Why do
we have media? Why do we have the
internet? And the point is to conjure
the consciousness of everyone in order
to manifest a reality that benefits the
elite. What's the purpose of this
reality? The ultimate purpose of this
reality is to extract energy from people
because that's the real wealth in the
universe, right? If the entire universe
is consciousness, then the real wealth
is the capacity to direct and extract
this consciousness and direct in a way
that benefits you. Okay? And and so
another way of saying this is attention.
Like if you can direct people's
attention, then you have all the power
in the world. Okay? And there are
different mechanisms that you can use to
direct attention. So the most easy the
most universal way is money right
because money has a way of focusing your
attention on on trying to obtain as much
of it as possible and then to support um
this idea where money is the center of
the universe is um the entire media e
ecosystem where when you read the news
uh like read it very carefully right
it's always like GDP okay what matters
is GDP how much money was made it's not
about happiness it's not about uh
well-being it's not about spirituality
It's about GDP. Okay. It's about human
life. Okay. So human life is an economic
commodity. So it's not about the quality
of life you you live. It's it's not
about how creative or imaginative you
are. It's about like you know like your
life is a set economic unit. If you if
you die then that's a uh downgrade of
GDP. Okay. So the entire world is to
focus your attention on money and make
you believe that money is God. that
money is the end all and be all and
that's a world we we live in uh in today
and [snorts]
but but what's key to understand is that
actually you know what money can go away
you don't really need money you you but
what you still need is to be able to
direct and control people's attention
that's why there are these fail saves in
the system okay and so the example
classic classic example is artificial
intelligence right why are they spending
so much money on developing artificial
intelligence is it really so that you
can generate porn videos online so you
can watch it. Is is it really so that
you have an AI go for it? No. The point
is that once money is gone, you gone,
you need a new god to replace money and
that has to be artificial intelligence,
a mechanism or device that can control
your entire perception. Okay? So
imagine, you know, like you're online
and this computer's talking to you. And
I I met people I have friends who tell
me like this AI is real and like I'm
trying to explain them, no, it's not
real. It's a goddamn hallucination.
Okay. All AI is is statistical modeling.
That's all it is. You're being fooled
and they don't get it. It's impossible
to explain. No, it's real. I talk to
him. I talk to the AI and the AI
understands me. Okay. So, so I mean
that's the fail safe. Once the money
system is gone, then you create a world
in which you know you everyone has
everyone lives in his own individual
matrix. Okay. It's it's it's like
literally that and like you spend all
your time on online talking to your AI
girlfriend and talking to God who will
tell you how to live a a better life.
And what they don't understand is that
uh behind this AI it's like the Wiz of
Oz. It's it's just like this old guy
like you know talking to you. Okay. And
it could be like literally you know like
lit literally it could be like millions
of Indians in a warehouse somewhere
talking to you and and you you think
it's God. you you you you you think
you're literally talking to like Natalie
Portman or someone or like [snorts]
Audrey Heard who's who's been brought
back from the dead. All right. So, so so
so yeah, I mean like the problem of
consciousness is that you know it's
beautiful. It leads to massive
creativity. The problem of consciousness
is like we cannot differentiate reality
from fantasy, right? We just can't do
it. So if so once this AI system is in
place then we all become prisoners in
Plato's uh cave. M also there there's um
several key elements to if if you add
into this understanding which will show
people that the way technology has
developed um all throughout the
scientific rational age probably is not
accidental as well in the sense of like
the reason why smartphones have
developed in the way they have is a
deliberate understanding of the way to
capture people's attention to keep them
distracted to keep them divided and uh
to keep them reactive emotionally. Um
just as most people don't realize that
the internet and Google were products of
the military and the CIA deliberately to
be able to collect data and to sort it
and to be able to filter through it and
use it for you know whatever purposes
they wanted to. And in a similar sense,
>> sorry, sorry, I hate to interrupt, but
but I I go deeper and say that science
itself was a creation of of of
Freemason. That's what I was about to
say.
>> Yeah. Isaac Newton, they're all
Freemasons,
>> right? Um
>> because what science does is is it um it
it one of its like biggest coups was
that it gave it it wiped away previous
history and put on top of it a new
interpretation of a place in the world
that was purposeless and seemingly
random. Yeah.
>> So it hid a lot of the deliberate
minations that were happening.
>> Exactly. So evolution, right? The theory
of evolution, it's a really problematic
theory, but like like think about how in
like 20 years time it was able to
conquer all of the world, right? So like
in 20 years time, all schools were
teaching the theory of evolution. And
like you're not allowed to create like
like it's it's the most dominant theory
in the world. And if like you ever
question evolution, say it's like did we
really evolve from apes? People would
just think you're insane. People would
would just think that you're this, you
know, this [ __ ] Okay. It's so
embedded in our everyday reality, like
this theory of of of evolution. Um Yeah.
>> Well, also, um it it means that uh
pe people I think we lost as a
population an understanding of what it
actually means to advance your
consciousness. uh whether that's
spiritually or in a secular sense
because um I have you know uh beginner
experience in some of the um eastern rel
religious traditions and uh it is very
clear that it is possible for people to
advance their consciousness into the uh
interpersonal and interplanetary cosmic
realms. Um but if that is not done in a
healthy way, it can also end up with
people who are actually very advanced in
their the power of their minds but who
have dark psychological pathological
shadows which are then incorporated into
the way they see the world. And I have a
sense that this is what has been
happening with the secret societies for
a long period of time in that they have
uh attained certain powers over the mind
and they have sought about using them
for because also there there is the I
think I I've taken this from your um
lectures as well. If you understand that
the nature of what we think to be
reality is not true and that there is a
sort of phenomena or a monad
and that what happens in this realm is
actually not as important as what
happens in the monad then that gives you
the if you're you know immorally
inclined that gives you the license to
behave however you want in this world
and
>> exactly
>> yeah you're exactly right and this goes
back to the alleg of the cave right
where one person escapes and he goes
into the monad the nana and he sees
reality for what it is just pure
consciousness pure light and at this
point he has he he can he has three
options right the first option is to
just stay where he is but he doesn't do
that because he feels pity for the
people below him so he goes down second
option is to go down and tell the truth
to people and then people just laugh at
him right and this leads to a third
option which is like well why not just
use this against people you know if you
know the truth then then you are the
oneeyed man in the kingdom of the god
blind right you What do you want?
>> And and and that's what the people in
power understand. Like if I understand
that mind um is everything,
consciousness is everything, then I'm
able to use this against people because
they don't understand this. PE people
understand people people think that
money is everything. But like what
matters is who prints the money, who
creates the money, who controls the
money, right? That's what matters.
Doesn't matter how much money you have.
Like you have a trillion dollars of like
fake money. Good for you, right?
Yeah. So that that takes me on to a a
question um that I'd like to direct more
to our the western audience. Um we've
spoken a bit about um the deeper
currents of thought and belief systems
within society that linger on for
millennia or hundreds of years at the
least. But we in the scientific rational
age kind of dismiss them as being
outdated or as if we have progressed
beyond them. And there are three there
was one particularly impactful period in
the Protestant Reformation
um which you've spoken about where this
question of uh how do I know if I'm
being a true believer to God came up and
there was three answers that were
created to that. There was the the
Calvinist work ethic, the the breaking
of taboos and I think the third one was
the um inner assurance and and self
introspection.
Um
you've spoken about the first two in
particular and how they sort of linger.
We you see them showing up in society
these days really shaping the way that
we um you know hail rich people because
they seem to have some gained the grace
of God. And you've spoken also about the
breaking of taboos uh as being more
involved in some of the the secret
societies activities as their way of
showing their filty to nobody but God.
Um what I don't see showing up in our
society is the third answer so much the
the inner assurance through
self-crutiny.
Um, do you have any understanding of why
that worked out the way it did? That
that two of the answers to that question
were very powerful and successful and
the third answer did not uh gain much
traction.
>> Yeah. Right. The Well, it's because the
idea of individuality, right? The the
idea of individual creativity is
greatest threat to the system because
your greatest act of rebellion is to
deny the reality before you and
establish your own reality. If everyone
did that, the system would collapse,
right? So the um active rebellion is not
to overturn the regime because whatever
what because if that ever happened, you
would just be the new regime doing
whatever they did before, right? That's
why we feel this continuity in the
system even though we know for a fact
that these dynasties, these individuals
have changed over time. So the idea, you
know, like I I've heard I've heard
conspiracy theorists say that, you know,
this goes back to the 13 families of
Rome, this goes back to um Venice, this
goes back to the uh Knights Tempest.
This is all nonsense. This is not how
humans behave. But the ideas passed on
from uh generation to generation. the
idea of how to construct a reality uh in
which you are able to enslave the
majority of people that's that's stayed
with us. And according to game theory
like even if this knowledge were not to
be passed on whoever's in charge would
just build a new a system like that
because that that is optimizing his
interests. Okay. So and so it feels as
though it's continuous but it's not. Um
so the only way out out of this is for
us as individuals because you know you
know we all have a connection to the
higher consciousness to the monad is for
us to embrace this consciousness and to
reject what um is before us. Okay to
reject money reject materialism to uh
reject status and say that what matters
to me is my own creativity. What matters
to me is my my impact on others around
me. My generosity, my openness, my
kindness. Um by acting with generosity,
I change the world for the better. Okay?
And that's a secret because because you
know people talk about a holographic
universe, right? What is a holographic
[clears throat] universe?
>> Um all all the universe is reflected in
us. And so if so we have the capacity to
change the universe for the better or
for the worse for our own individual
actions. Once we once we embrace our um
unique individuality, once we embrace
our the power of our consciousness and
once we um understand our own
responsibility to the universe, then we
have to participate in the world in a
way that benefits everyone. and and and
and that um is the act greatest act of
rebellion. It's actually an act that
requires the most courage because what
you're talking really about is
abandoning your family, abandoning your
friends, abandoning the society that you
grew up in. Okay? It's it's like
basically
>> jumping off a cliff and expecting to
land, right? But like no, you like you
you you've been taught that you jump off
a cliff, you're going to die. But you
you know in your heart that when you
jump off the cliff, you're just going to
fly. And like I mean I mean I mean I
mean if you said that to people, people
people would just think you're crazy.
[snorts]
Yeah, absolutely. And I I
[clears throat] mean this week uh it
seems that um
people are being pushed in this
direction uh whether they like it or not
through the the things that we're
finding out about the world through the
Epstein files where um a lot of people
describe like you couldn't make this up
as if it was a movie script.
things seem to be playing out uh in a
almost theatrical way that is so
shocking as to force people to start
waking up. Um I I know that there's many
people in the spiritual world who see
this as a you know almost divine
intervention style of period that we're
that we're going through. Um but it does
seem quite clear that there is a level
of um waking up and waking up into
responsibility for ourselves that we are
we are passing through. Um I I actually
started to notice this through Osama bin
Laden's letter to America. Um which you
know they the deep state did a great job
of trying to uh repress when it came up
again at the beginning of the genocide
in in Gaza. But what he his one of his
main messages to Americans in that was
you need to take responsibility for the
actions of your government as citizens
if you want to claim to be a democracy
because under your democratic logic. You
are, you know, electing the people that
will carry out policies on your behalf.
And if that this is what they're going
to do to our people, these are the
consequences you can expect to see. So
in a sense it it was a it was an
original wakeup call that that he gave.
I you know there's so much about his
links to the CIA and and other things
that I won't go into now but in some
ways these type of events called us to
wake up to the reality that we live in.
>> Yeah. So I think the greatest shock of
Epson files is people recognize that the
elite they're not special. Okay. They're
not they're not smarter. They're not
moral. They're not more they're not more
moral. They're not more competent. Okay.
They can spell properly. Okay.
>> Um and and that's the great truth of
this world. The people in positions of
power are there because they were born
into positions of power. That that's
something I discovered when I went to
Yale. I go to Yale and I expecting like
this, you know, this heaven of
intellectual uh brilliance and it's not.
Even the professors were mediocre. Uh
they were just like I mean like I was
like, "Oh my god, this is like my high
school, but it's bigger. That's all it
is. And and so like and and and you know
that's what people need to recognize
that the elite are just you and me.
Okay. The only difference is they have
all the power and power corrupts. And so
and so like I was talking to my wife
about why Jeffrey Epstein was doing what
he was doing. Like like why are they
doing this? Because like it's
disgusting. And her explanation uh makes
the most sense. So I mean my my my wife
she's not from a powerful family but she
grew up in a very powerful organization
and and from an early age she's dealt
with powerful people. Okay. So she she
knows what they're like. Okay. She she
explain to me how they are. Okay. So the
powerful people are usually born into
position of of privilege. And if if
you're like that there's no excitement
in your life. There's no challenge.
There's no it's only just privilege. And
privilege is boring. It's numbing. Okay.
So for them the greatest challenge is
how do you find excitement? How do you
stir a feeling in your heart in this
world? And our explanation is you do it
for children. Okay. Why? Well, first of
all, you know, it's like having having a
doll, right? A doll you can play with, a
cat you can play off play with. But
childrens are much more exciting. Uh you
can play with them, you can control
them, you can manipulate them, you can
abuse them. And the other thing is that
you can scare children much more e
easily. Okay. So you know this
conspiracy theory where uh the elite
draw energy from uh enginrome okay uh
and and denochrome okay and you and
endocchrom is just you know um blood
that is excited blood that comes from
fear okay and and if you and and so you
drink that blood because this blood is
is rejuvenating well it's that that's a
metaphorical statement where as a
powerful person and you see a child um
in fear that excites you that excites
you both sexually and psychologically
and emotionally and and and so you know
you have you seen these videos of like
Prince Prince Andrew just running around
and grabbing children and he was like
really really excited really really
happy when he's doing that and and the
reason why is that's the only thing that
can bring him excitement another um
example is a Squid Game. I'm not sure if
you've seen the Netflix series The Squid
Game, right? The entire premise of the
Squid Game is you have all these rich
people in South Korea and they have the
most money in the world. They can do
whatever they want. they can like sleep
with like the like the most beautiful
movie star in the world. They don't want
to do that because it's boring.
Okay, they're looking for some
excitement in their life and that's they
that's why they create the Squid Game.
All right, so the Squid Game is just a
metaphor for Epcor,
man. They're bored by everything.
They're bored by their own lives.
They're bored by the people around them
because they're all psychopontants.
They're bored by power itself because um
they they've experienced it all. And so
like they're looking for like novelty in
their lives and that's what children
bring. Okay. There's also and and then
and I was like why are they so blatant
about this? And my wife says it's
psychology where you have to have a risk
of getting caught. You have to have the
risk of being exposed in order for this
to be exciting. Okay? If it's all just
hidden from everyone and no one can ever
find out and there's no risk, it's not
funny. It's not funny anymore. Right?
So, so, so I I I understand this sounds
really um disturbing, but unfortunately,
if you give a certain group of people
too much power, then this is the way
they behave and and this has been true
historically. Okay, you look at any
society in China. Guess what guys, we do
the same thing. All right? Don't don't
think that oh, Chinese are more superior
because of confusionism. Don't think
that the Indians are superior because of
their Vic tradition. No, everyone's the
same. If you put position of p if you
put people in position of power, they're
going to abuse it. All right? And what
they want ultimately is novelty,
excitement, feeling. All right? So like
just you and me, we we feel a tremendous
rush when we achieve something. Well,
they've achieved it all. So so so they
need the sort of like sadistic satanic
rituals in order to feel alive again.
Look, the other thing that has not been
in the Epson files, but I'm sure there's
lots of them, are snuff films. Okay.
>> I'm sure there's lots of these things um
because that's what they do, man.
>> Yep. Yeah. I I can't help but feel like
um [clears throat] I mean I know this is
repeated through all cultures and and
ages, but it does seem to have some
links to um the broader cultural malaise
and lack of meaning that we see in the
west currently.
um where you you you kind of mentioned
this in your uh lecture about
gerontocracy
where we have a a class of people who at
the top of the society who do not want
to budge um they control all the wealth
um and they're you know a bit uncreative
but this seems to me to be a a
representation of where the society is
at in general the whole western society
seems geriatric in a sense
Um, and there's some other things that
you mentioned about the anglophere in
your lectures. I think starting with
Shakespeare, but you mentioned it with
um, some of the other great English
literature works that English as a
language has this propensity to be used
with a lot of dazzle and show, but with
less actual substantive meaning to it in
comparison to other languages. And we
know that language shapes our the way
our mind works in particular.
Um, so I wanted to ask you if if is
there something that you've seen in the
Anglosphere and in English language in
particular that has led itself towards
this society that lacks any meaning? It
can produce great orators and people
with a lot of enter entertainment value
but not actually any real ideas or
contribution to civilization.
>> Yeah. I I think um yeah no I I think a
lot of that h stems from the fact that
Britain was an island right and as an
island you you you're very provincial
you're very insular in the way you you
perceive the world and when Britain
became an empire it didn't become more
cosmopolitan it didn't become much more
deep and insightful it just spread it
elementality throughout the world
include the angosphere right so you go
to Australian these are pretty
provincial people. You could go to
Canada. Yeah.
>> Pretty provincial, man.
>> I I grew up in Canada. These are pretty
stupid people.
>> Um, and like you said the same in
Australia as well, right? So, so it
isn't like, you know, okay, we're not an
empire and we need to be much more
cosmopolitan. We we need to create a
cosmopolitan culture. No, it's not like,
no, no, no. They just spread their
island mentality throughout the world.
Mhm. Because I I feel like this is part
of what is showing up in the the the
sort of social crisis of the west as
well in that uh you know there is the
mental health crisis, loneliness,
individualism
uh you know the for young men uh the
highest
uh cause of death is diseases of
despair. Um,
and is this an inevitable
uh, you know, dead end for Western
consumer society? Or have you seen or
thought of any ways that the Western
world could restore meaning to its
people and to its, you know,
civilizational direction and and
purpose?
>> Yeah, I think this is the end. Um, and
I'm extremely pessimistic about this. I
think that we're headed to about 100
years of like permanent decline. Um and
this is very similar to the bronze age
collapse where unfortunately one system
of thought you know like this consumer
liberal democracy has conquered the
world right so Francis Fukayama talks
about this in the end of history where
there's really no other competing
ideology against uh consumer uh liberal
democracy and it's really conquered the
world including China okay including
China I like I yes I understand China is
authoritarian society but it it has a
lot of the um basic worldview uh of the
consumer liberal democratic mentality
which is like the consumer is
everything. Um money is what matters.
Materialism is all that matters. Okay.
So this idea has really conquered the
the world and unfortunately
um there can't be another system that
could
replace this system. Okay. So what's
going to happen is this system is going
to fracture and so we're living in a
time when we've reached the peak of
globalization
and it's amazing to think about okay but
think think about how I could be sitting
in China and I could be making money in
United States and this money from United
States is wired immediately to my bank
account in China converted from US
dollars to RB immediately and I can use
this to go to the store and buy avocados
from Mexico. I can buy I can use to buy
chilies from cherries from Chile. Okay,
this is an incredible system that we
have and like tomorrow if I want I could
board a plane and go to Maldives to to
scuba dive and pay it all with with a
Chinese credit card. It's amazing the
system we have, but it's not sustainable
because it doesn't provide any meaning
to the world. Um it's one of decadence.
It's one of corruption. It it's it's one
that's antihuman because again we're
consciousness. We're here on this world
to expand the conscious consciousness of
ourselves as well as the universe. And
that means a a life of struggle,
hardship, and pain. I'm sorry to say
this, but that's a life we should live.
And instead, we've chosen a life of easy
uh luxury, decadent corruption. Okay? We
we choose the easier path rather than
the harder path. Even even though the
only path to enlightenment, the only
path to only path to wisdom is through
the harder path by climbing a mountain.
Um and and so uh the universe is going
to punish us for this. Okay. Um because
this is not why we're here. And the
universe is like, "Okay guys, if you
want to play this game, then we're going
to play this game." Okay? So the big
thing to watch out for is something
called the magnetic pole excursion. And
the manic pole excursion um is going to
basically reset the game. It's going to
destroy the world. 99% of us will be
dead in about 50 years time. Um, and you
know, like listen, like just just go on
the net and like look at Antarctica and
if you melt all the ice, what happens?
You find it's actually two or three
different continents together. Okay? And
if you keep keep on looking further,
you'll find some ancient structures
there. Go to Amazon, there's lots of
ancient structures in the Amazon. Okay?
Um, biologists believe the Amazon was
um, man-made. Actually, you you go to go
play a tepe. Okay? So, we look, humans
have been around for about 200,000
years. We have about 10,000 years of our
history. I cannot believe that these
200,000 years were just hunter
gatherers, you know, roaming the a
frozen world. Look, they built Kai Hoyak
in like a in like a few decades. You you
go like any society and like they're
very quickly able to build cities um if
they put their minds to it. Okay. So, so
we so we're not the first great
civilization. And the idea that you know
this is all theological and that we've
reached the peak of human civilization,
it's not true. Go look at the pyramids,
man. We have absolutely no idea how they
built the pyramids and we couldn't even
do the pyramids ourselves. Okay. Um, so
so what's what's amazing to think about
is that there are other human
civilizations civilizations that that
existed before us and in many ways
they're much more advanced than us.
They're so much more advanced that we
can imagine what they were like. Okay?
Just as they can imagine what we're like
today, we can't even imagine what they
were like before. And so that's that's a
greatness of human civilization where if
conscious is the universe, we can
manifest reality in any way that we
imagine. If we put our collective minds
to it and we have the correct values,
then we create the civilization on on
earth. So so we create the civilization
because of our material greed, right?
Whereas before may maybe before they
create the civilizations based on a
spiritual uh on spiritual enlightenment.
All right? So you you look at the
harapen civilization right the uh in
this valley civilization extremely
peaceful egotarian and spiritual and so
so we're able to create any civilization
that we want um and the problem today is
we we created a material greedy
civilization that can only destroy us
and it's destroying us spiritually um I
think never before in human history have
have people become have been have people
been so depressed so lonely um so so
hopeless
Yeah, I think this is um an important
point to just draw out from what some of
the examples you've given and what we've
spoken about previously today is that um
the f but whether it's on the individual
level all the way through to the global
level talking about globalization
the further we live at a distance from
reality the further into delusions we
live about uh ourselves or about the
world the harder the crash is when those
delusions turn out to be wrong. So
globalization you can sense in a in just
in a very menial way of like
>> I can buy fruit from all around the
world at any time of the year at any
time of the day that gives me a sense of
uh you know abundance or luxury that is
actually built on false frail structures
that can collapse and we have been
pushing kicking the can down the road of
that delusion for so long that the
collapse is going to be very hard. And
just as in an individual life, it is
usually only when people reach rock
bottom that they actually start to wake
up and they may turn towards
spirituality and and start to reflect
upon themselves. It feels like that is
what we're going to have to go through
collectively to return to a more
wholesome way of living in the world.
>> And the reality is that most of us will
not be able to do this. Okay? So what's
going to kill us is not these natural
disasters or war or famine. What's going
to kill us is our our incapacity to be
resilient, our incapacity to be
open-minded. Um so so and I I mean
that's that's what what's going to kill
most people. And it's particularly um
the biggest vulnerability in the western
world which retains very little sense of
spiritual faith because I I've spent a
lot of time in in my professional life
uh living in and working in places like
Lebanon, Jordan and Syria where um
practiced daily faith was a huge
component of the way people have dealt
with difficulties and maintained social
cohesion for decades now or centuries
really. Um and that shows me that you
know when everything in life comes
crumbling down what do you draw on to
get up and get on with the day. That is
something that I don't see anywhere in
the western world
>> and and the classic example is the
Palestinians. They've been for
everything. Okay. And in the Israeli
mindset these people have have should be
in Egypt right now, right? Why are they
still around? So they've been, you know,
bombed. Um they've there's abely no
reason for them to go on. they but you
know they're having more children and
that's a power of faith and that's why
they they're so resilient. That's why
they're um they can't be defeated.
>> That's right.
Um so just as a as a final question um I
would like to you know we've spoken so
much about like a pulling away of these
delusions and and stories that people
live within. Um, do you see any like I
know you've already said you're
relatively pessimistic about this. Um,
but it is there any chance that we with
the development of AI, we move from we
we we sort of replace the knowledge
economy that we live in today in
advanced societies with AI. And because
there is, you know, not a lot left to do
mentally that we could return to
actually working on the soul and the the
earth and the things that we need to
sustain ourselves.
Um
>> yeah.
>> Yeah. Like to hear your thoughts about
that.
>> Right. So AI um doesn't mean more
leisure time. It means the enslavement
of uh mankind. It means the um capture
capturing of all conscious energy.
Right? So the idea of AI is to create a
surveillance state where you're
microchipped
um where everything is digital digital
ID digital currency wherever you go your
movement is monitored
um and if you're do anything that is
slightly wrong you're nudged in the
right direction okay so maybe your
internet goes off or your bank account
is frozen okay so it's complete 100%
surveillance it's it's a matrix and it's
meant to enslave us and it's it's like
again Plato's algo of the cave where
you're literally now chained down and
you can only stare at a screen. You can
only see what people want you to see.
That's what AI uh a is. It's the idea of
like you know AI is like freedom from
work and [snorts] it will free us up for
more uh you know spiritual endeavors.
That's just complete nonsense. It's
gaslighting. That's not what it is.
>> Right.
>> I think people need to remember that
man. I know what it is. I've I've seen
the future and it's China. Mhm. Well,
yeah. I was I often reference to people
that they should go back and watch the
Jetsons, the cartoon from the 50s and
60s that were sort of the original
propaganda about what technology would
lead us to that we would have all this
leisure time and the robots would be
doing the work. But nobody actually
really asks where is that today.
They don't see that technological
development is, you know, from an
economic perspective just about
replacing the cost of humans. And yeah,
and then once we're not necessary, then
that becomes about figuring out ways to
control us,
>> right? And and and look, I mean, a book
every should read is Brave New World,
okay? Because that that is the future,
right? Um so the drugs drugs will be a
very important part of this um new world
as well new world order as well where
it's not just AI surveillance it's also
like drugs right so um you know if you
take vaccines you don't know what they
put in there right uh you don't know
what they put in fast foods you don't
know what to put in the water but trust
me it's not good
>> I think I have a question um maybe some
of your audience would like to to hear
as well is like Um, how do your students
respond to uh your teaching? You know,
this is not a uh orthodox
history class that they're getting into
at such a young age. And I know a lot of
people are sort of reliving their high
school years through your lectures in a
very, you know, enlightening way. Um, h
how do you see your students attitude to
the world uh changing after what they're
learning?
So the reality is that most students
zone out. They don't even come to class.
All right? So I I'm like 16 students a
class, but like maybe one or two will
show up. Okay? And those one or two show
up, their lives are changed forever
>> because you know, they'll go home, you
know, they'll ask their parents like,
you know, I've I learned this in class
and what do you think? And you know,
they like like it's it's going to force
them to think much more deep deeper
about the world. It's gonna force them
to be much more observant about the
world and it's gonna open their minds
and that's the point of this um
education. I make a lot of mistakes in
my in my teachings, you know, um because
I'm dealing with so much material
>> and a lot of what I'm doing is
intuitive, you know. I'm not like a
research scholar where I spend like
years researching a topic to make sure
every detail is correct. I'm much more
intuitive. I'm just trying to speculate
about how the world would work. Um, you
know, it's it and you know, I'm driven a
lot and you can probably tell this in my
lecture. I'm driven by by my own
curiosity, right? He's like, I don't
know these people. I don't know if this
stuff is true or not. I'm just doing a
thought experiment in my head. Like,
okay, how can we explain what happened?
Um, and and and so I'm really much more
interested in teaching thought processes
than I am about teaching, you know, the
truth about the world.
>> Fantastic. Well, I personally and I'm
sure many others really appreciate your
contributions and be looking forward to
seeing how [clears throat] you track
developments in the coming months and
years. And let's hope we all make it
through this as safely and sely as
possible.
>> Look, look, um
if you want to make it through, you
will. Okay? A lot of it is pure will. Um
and unfortunately
um what we've been trained to believe is
that we're powerless. We're not. We we
we we are capable of our we are capable
of creating our own reality. And so it's
really about um your desire to be
resilient. And a lot of your desire to
be resilient just based on what you
think the point of life is. If you think
the point of life is to make as much
money as possible, well guess what? You
won't survive uh the coming crisis. But
if you if you think that you know your
the point of your existence is to learn
as much as possible to seek wisdom to
seek enlightenment to help others do as
well as to do as well. Well, this coming
age of darkness it's it's it's it's for
you um a time for you
a time for you to shine.
>> Fantastic. Thank you for that message.
I'm sure everyone appreciates it. Thank
you very much for your time, Dr. Today,
Dr. young. We'll have to speak to speak
again soon in the future.
>> Thank you, Alex.